[Music]
the first quarterback to be disgruntled
this year
was uh deshawn watson tariq cohen when
not
trying to get russell wilson to come to
chicago is also
trying to get deshaun watson to come to
chicago terry cohen would take
either of them sorry mitch trubisky but
he knows
mitch knows he's sufficiently self-aware
to know he's not desean watson he's not
russell wilson cohen would take either
plenty of players recruiting either
watson or russell wilson let's focus on
desean watson a couple of news items
that came up yesterday i i guess that
you know the desean watson story felt
neglected by the russell wilson story's
attention
so two or three big items first
reportedly the texans will not even talk
to teams who
call so offers are being left
on voicemail for the houston texans for
deshaun watson peter i mean it sounds
like
the texans are like plugging their
fingers in their ears and saying
not listening in order to adhere to this
predetermined position
that we're not trading him no matter
what and no one can make us an offer we
can't refuse
if we never actually hear what the offer
is
i have a i don't know
about leaving offers on voicemail i
you know look i wrote the other day
in my column that basically uh
you know the the general manager of the
texans
you know i almost said the general
manager of the texans jack easterby
the general manager of the texas area
i i i almost said the other day or i
said the other day that
that nick casario is not entertaining
offers
period he'll talk about any of any other
player on his team
anyone but he's not talking about desean
watson
okay so that's that
is the way it is okay now
as far as whether that is smart or
whether that's dumb
well the reason that if if i were fully
intending to not trade him
and and i would love to get into a
very long theoretical discussion
about you know whether a player
who's gotten paid 28.1 million dollars
in
in four months and it
has one thing apparently one thing even
though the franchise is collapsing
but as one thing go wrong a very serious
thing but one thing go wrong
all of a sudden says i'm never playing
for the franchise again
i guess my question went wrong what
what's the one thing that you think went
wrong
because i feel like cal mcnair cal
mcnair
cal mcnair misled him on whether he was
going to have some true input
on who the uh you know who the who the
new coach
and or gm would be okay that seems like
a pretty big
thing it is a big thing but let me ask
you this question let me ask you this
question
that if if if that one thing goes wrong
if that one thing goes wrong does that
mean
that you absolutely categorically said
they have crossed the rubicon i will
never play for this franchise again
i mean think about that think about that
why would
any team any team sign a player to a
long-term contract
after this knowing that after he got
a huge amount of guaranteed money in
year one after four or five months
he could get so angry that he would say
i'm not playing here again
you know i think anything that would do
that peter any any team that would do it
as long as they are committed to being
honest and truthful and forthright with
their players
they can rest assured that those issues
won't happen if cal mcnair had simply
lived up to the word that he
communicated or that he clumsily
communicated inadvertently and
incorrectly because that
theory is popping around now that he
really didn't mean to give
desean watson the boy you did too bad
you did you got to own it now
i think it all comes down to how you
handle your player and
this happened more quickly than russell
wilson but it got off the rails
and how it got to this point as an
indictment of the organization
and i feel bad for casario he's the one
in there with a mop trying to figure out
where to start cleaning up
he he's going to be cleaning up all year
and beyond
and and and you know watson won't even
talk to him
so uh yeah you can still pay a player
but mike i guess give the guy money
doesn't mean you can mistreat him
i'm not saying i'm not saying that he
wasn't mistreated but i'm saying
in nfl history okay in nfl history
do you think any major player for a team
uh has been misled and or lied to by a
team
yes probably about a thousand times and
how many times has the best player in an
organization
then basically forced his way off the
island
and and the only point i'm making in
this is and the reason that i believe
that
that this is uh this is a time in nfl
history
that we're going to look back on and say
things really changed
uh you know hugely in nfl history
is because you are now seeing
uh you know matthew stafford different
story but he walks into the owner and
says i want to get traded
they trade him tom brady totally
different story
totally different story but tom brady
says
i want out he gets out okay and then now
you're seeing two more quarterbacks of
huge
immense pedigree you know two top five
top six quarterbacks in the nfl could
both
be saying i want out and they get out so
all i'm saying is i wonder why
i would sign a player long term
right now maybe you don't unless you're
going to take
better care of him and not give the keys
to the franchise that jack used to be we
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports